today on the matt walsh show caitlyn
jenner attended cpec over the weekend
reigniting the debate about whether this
person in any sense represents
conservatism
i will give an emphatic no to that
question also our five headlines
including cubans waving american flags
as they protest communism
ben carson upsets a lot of people with
an entirely correct by the way statement
about the black family and the san
francisco gay men's chorus after
releasing that song
warning that they're coming for our
children have now decided that they are
the victims because of the backlash they
received
in response to it and in our daily
cancellation we'll discuss camila
harris's claim
that rural americans don't have access
to photocopiers
as a former rural american myself i have
some thoughts about that and much more
today
on the matt walsh show
[Music]
the great conservative hope caitlyn
jenner was attending cpac
in dallas over the weekend now in
fairness to cpac as far as i know
he was not there to give a speech nor
was he involved in any other official
sort of capacity
as far as i know but he did hit the
interview circuit where he rattled off a
series of republican cliches
this sort of thing apparently still
impresses some of the more mentally
deficient members
of the right wing here's jenner for
example talking to uh this is right side
broadcasting network
at cpac cpac explaining generally
speaking his his
kind of uh approach and his stance as a
conservative
let's listen yes there are so many
career politicians out there it is
is it going to be an easy job no no but
as an outsider
i am not the one who gave us the highest
tax rates in the nation one of the
highest tax rates in the nation
regulations on top of regulations um
this the list goes on and on and on of
what you say the career politicians have
done to the state of california
i don't know one special interest
any favor whatsoever i don't know one
union what i want to do is come in
and represent the people right now the
people in california are not represented
i'm an outsider taxes are bad
regulations career politicians special
interests the people
rah-rah-rah i'm so tired of hearing this
you might as well put a bunch of
conservative buzzwords into a magic
8-ball
and shake it up and see what it says you
might as well interview a magic eight
ball
stuffed with conservative talking points
if you can still be swept off your feet
by this kind of thing
from a republican politician or want to
be a republican politician then i don't
know what to tell you
i could teach a literal parrot like an
actual parrot a bird
to say everything that jenner just said
there and that's all he has by the way
that's this whole pitch standard issue
republican claptrap doesn't get much
deeper than that
proving the point here jenner did have
an opportunity at cpac to talk about
uh his vision for the america first
movement and what america first
means to him personally and here's what
he said here with caitlyn jenner
tell me what does america first mean to
you it needs
exactly what it says we need to put
america first
um i have been around this country for a
long time you know i've been lived out
in california for 48 years
i've seen what is happening out there
we're losing the state
18 000 companies have left high taxes
this and that
we got to put america first we got to
put the people of california
first and that's what i'm fighting for
america first means uh you know america
first that's that's the thing about
being america first i just i really
believe in
america being first it's just such you
know
america it's an america firsty type of
thing
uh this and that vote for me
that was my favorite part of the answer
was uh this and that you know as
high taxes and businesses and this and
that i don't know
you don't get to this and that because i
know about the tax department but
what else give me a little bit more than
that
you can't this and that your way out of
this
somehow i am not persuaded and yet i'm
constantly reminded by conservatives
that this is different sure gender is at
best
a typical establishment republican type
at best
serving up a bunch of reheated
microwaved gop talking points from 2003
but he's doing it while wearing a dress
and that changes everything yes what
makes jenner especially appealing
what makes him a more compelling
candidate than your typical
pre-programmed
republibot is that he also offers us the
opportunity to completely abandon our
defense of biological reality by
embracing the trans agenda
and left-wing gender theory all in one
fell swoop
this is supposed to be a selling point
somehow
now for the mass of diluted saps who who
do consider it a selling point
i thought this would be a good
opportunity to review
um a few things about jenner in fact we
could do this in chronological order
uh some some things that maybe have been
forgotten
starting shortly after jenner's stunning
announcement that he is becoming a woman
and uh and going up until now let's
review the positions that he's taken and
the sorts of things
he's been saying and advocating we can
begin in 2015. here's a clip that has
kind of flown
under the radar for the last six years
uh now that jenner is being embraced as
a representative of the conservative
movement i think it warrants a second
look this is jenner at an lgbt
fundraiser it's about six years ago
recounting a hilarious and heartwarming
incident that occurred in his home
when his children were much younger
listen
one daughter's was stealing the other
daughter's clothes
okay so she set her computer up in the
room
and she put on that like security device
that if anybody walked in it would
videotape them
okay i didn't know that okay
so so everybody's gone i got like three
or four hours let's try on a few things
here
and and
i come and all of a sudden the kids come
home and i hear this big commotion going
on in the other room
and chris goes in here
yeah sometimes i was very stealthy i i
honestly i went all these years
i mean i i would go to hotels processes
and that and never get caught i have to
i'm proud of that okay
proud of that not to be clear just so
we're all on the same page here
i think it's pretty pretty clear cut but
he went into his daughter's room
and tried on her clothes um
now imagine how traumatizing it would be
for a young girl to uh
find out maybe if you're if you're a
woman watching this and
you think back uh to when you were
younger and
just imagine finding out that your dad
is invading your privacy
rifling through your closets and drawers
and wearing your clothing
when you leave the home if a girl
confided in you
that like today if a young girl came up
and confided in you
that her dad had done this you'd
probably call the police
you would assume rightly that the child
is not safe in that home
you wouldn't tell her to laugh it off oh
there's old dad up to his crazy hijinks
again
you know dad's wearing their daughter's
clothing happens all the time
in fact even if this was um you know
even this even this was a mom
acting like this let's pretend this is a
woman doing
this sneaking into her daughter's room
to try on her clothes
it would be extremely weird and creepy
and a sign that something is not right
in that home but this is not the mom
despite what we may be told now
this is the dad cross-dressing in his
daughter's clothing
and he does he does refer to it that way
by the way as cross-dressing
we can all agree that that this is
disturbing and inappropriate at an
absolute minimum
we can all agree with that until the
father comes out as quote trans at which
point it magically becomes
laudable i mean the audience is
literally applauding it
clapping and then jenner is embraced as
a champion of conservative values
continuing on our tour here uh our tour
here is jenner
sometime in 2016 on tucker carlson in a
clip that was reposted to twitter by a
guy named
bryson gray and which is good to be
reposted so we can all remember this
but here's jenner confessing where his
real
loyalties lie and you can listen here is
it america is it his states
not really listen my loyalty do not lie
with the republican party
my loyalties and what i'm fighting for
is my community the lgbt community and
particularly the trans issues that are
out there
because there are many of them um and so
that's where my fight is
okay his loyalties lie primarily not
with his country not with the state but
with the
lgbt community this is this is not
america first rather it is quite
expressly
lgbt first america first and lgbt first
are not the same thing
and will never be the same thing finally
in a clip that we we have played on the
show before here is jenner only a few
months ago
um explaining that he does support males
in women's sports but with one qualifier
and it's a qualifier that only makes his
position
more demented and extreme listen and you
notice i did not say
in that statement trans women i said
biological boys what i would do is
as governor i would put together a
commission trans women can compete in
the olympics they compete in the ncaa
but when it gets down to the high school
level there's no guide rules there's no
rules and regulations
how they can and trans women who are
truly trans
who at a very young age you know started
proper medical treatment they've grown
up as girls of course they should be
able to compete in girls sports
but yeah as some guy who hasn't done any
therapy hasn't done anything
there has to be a review board i'd be
the first governor to put together a
review board to review each case
such a small issue it's like a non-issue
that's out there
and i would be surprised if there's 30
trans athletes
in the entire state he's not running as
a trans activist who says even though
he's previously said that his loyalties
are with the lgbt community and trans
issues primarily
more to the point all at once we see
that jenner not only supports putting
males in girls sports but he also
supports medical treatment quote unquote
for boys at quote a very young age
to transition them into girls it doesn't
specify what it means by very young age
but
i think we all know what that means and
he wants some sort of state commission
put in place to examine these boys and
determine if they have received enough
medical treatment quote unquote to now
officially qualify his girls how's that
gonna work
we're gonna have some some commission of
of weirdos who bring these boys in and
take a look and say yeah
he's a girl he'll pass
throw him in the girls track team this
one no he's
got to do uh two more years of hormones
on this one
that position is actually worse than the
typical left-wing stance on this issue
and frankly before jenner came along
with this idea i didn't know
it could get worse so what are we left
with
a man who confessed to cross-dressing in
his young daughter's clothing
now identifies as a woman and says that
his loyalties are with the lgbt
community
and who supports medicating young boys
to turn them into girls
and who holds no authentic conservative
views that he can explain or defend with
any coherency or depth
that's it but then again he has an r
next to his name and he uses words like
tax cuts and regulations that's enough
apparently for him to be accepted as a
conservative which is to say
that the word conservative much like the
word woman
no longer means anything at all now
let's get to our five headlines
now checking in with rock auto you know
if you're having car trouble if you need
parts for your car you're you're at a a
fork
in the road and you have two choices
before you one one is that you could go
to a
auto parts store walk around the aisles
aimlessly looking for what you need you
can't find it they order it online
or they just don't have it in stock at
all you know whatever it is you could do
that waste all your time or you could
just go to
rockauto.com and going to rockauto.com
is so easy because all you got to do is
pull out your phone
type it in and you can find the lowest
prices
anywhere if you see it at rockauto.com
you know that you're getting the best
possible price you don't have to keep
shopping around comparing quotes and all
that kind of stuff they're a family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers the
catalog is unique
and what i like most about it is that
it's very easy to navigate you don't
have to know a lot about cars to find
what you're looking for which is good
because if you did then i'd never be
able to find anything on rockauto.com
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brand specifications and prices you
prefer
so go now to rockauto.com and see all
the parts available for your car
truck and remember as always to write
walsh in there how did you hear about
usbox so they know that we sent you
so this is exciting starting off here
number one with
the report from the daily wire sir
richard branson on sunday won the space
race among his fellow billionaires we've
got this
the billionaire space race has been
happening and richard branson
won it rocketing to an altitude of more
than 53 miles above the earth considered
space by u.s agencies in doing so
he became the first earthling to soar
into space in his own vehicle
um so this was the first private
the first guy to take his own spaceship
into space
uh in a now we should also stipulate
uh he he was only up there i think it
was okay
14-minute flight branson at the age of
70
uh the founder of virgin airlines and
now virgin galactic beat out rival jeff
bezos
founder of amazon who's planning to fly
to space in a rocket just nine days from
now
uh you gotta you gotta feel bad for jeff
bezos on that one
maybe not about 500 people including
branson's wife children and
grandchildren who had
had gathered at the runway in truth or
consequences
um new mexico cheered when the space
plane
landed so he was up there for uh was
14 minutes and there was like three
minutes of flightlessness
so it's it's is about as as
low as you could go while still being
considered space and that's where he
went
now you know i see online there are
people
saying that oh okay well this is this is
what space flight is going to be now
it's just something for rich people to
do
and that's all this is and what's the
big deal it's never going to be
accessible to
normal people there's never going to be
a time when like people like me and you
or
can go up into space and that may be
true
but you also have to keep in mind that
this is always the precursor to
something
being available to the masses i mean
anytime there's some
extraordinary new technology it all
maybe not always but oftentimes it
begins with rich people
before it gets to everybody else uh cell
phones
cars microwaves
tvs i mean i can still remember a time
when having a big screen tv
was it was a big deal and was like a
sign of wealth and privilege
in the 90s and i'd go to my you know i'd
go to my i
had a friend and his dad was like a
lawyer or something and they had a
big screen tv and the thing was like 900
tons the picture quality was terrible
and it probably cost like 10 grand now
anyone can buy one for
300 bucks at walmart and they hang on
your wall
so that's generally the way things go um
and right now space is this
activity for rich people but won't
necessarily always be that way
that's my positive spin on it and you
don't often get positive spins from me
but there it is
another positive element for this from
the daily wire as well says massive
protests erupt on sunday in cuba
as citizens of the island nation
demanded an end to the communist
dictatorship
as they suffer in poverty while having
limited freedom the new york times
reported quote in a country known for
repressive crackdowns on dissent the
rallies were widely reviewed as
astonishing
quote activists and analysts called it
the first time that so many people had
openly protested against the communist
government since the so-called
um since uh the uprising in 1994
in a huge wave of cuba cubans leaving
the country by sea there were also
people
a lot of images of this online you
probably saw many of them
uh some of the protesters waving
american flags and there's the
kind of sad irony that's been observed
um where you've got
some cubans who have a more a
more patriotic attachment to the united
states of america
than many americans do
um when you see this
and you see people in cuba under a
communist regime
against that regime and rightfully so
there's always this question that comes
up
and it's really it's we could get away
from the economic
from the specifically economic questions
and just broaden it
and talk about human flourishing human
well-being
because that's what we should be
concerned about
um and
at the end of the day the best system is
going to be a system
that that helps the most people flourish
as human beings
so has there ever been a time when we
look back in history
we know the people in cuba are not
flourishing and they certainly don't
feel like they're flourishing which is
why what's
this is happening now has there ever
been a time
when communism increased
human flourishing
when when a communist system was not in
place and then it was put in place
and suddenly now there is more human
flourishing
and we see an increase in human
well-being
has that ever happened in history is
there one example of that happening
the answer of course is no now the the
advocates
for communism in america today and
unfortunately there are many of them
if they had an example they would just
provide it
because i'm not the first person to
think of this argument this this is the
really the argument against
communism um
is that we don't have to talk in theory
about it it's not a theory it's an
actual system
we've seen how it works and
we've seen every single time misery
despair and death
so at a certain point maybe you learn a
lesson from that
if the advocates had even one example
they would point it but they never do
instead what do we always get we always
get the tried and true rejoinder
that well that's not real communism
real communism has never been tried
all of these are fake they thought it
was gonna be real communism and it
turned out it was fake communism
so we gotta keep on trying until we get
the real thing
um next year ben carson
was at was also at cpac and he was
interviewed on stage talked about many
subjects
but at a certain point he starts talking
about the the state of the black family
here in the united states what he said
here has caused lots of controversy and
outrage
from the left and the right people are
are are very upset at uh ben carson for
saying this but let's both listen to it
and then
i don't know we'll we'll decide if
there's anything wrong with what he said
let's listen
when you look at what the black
community has been through
go all the way back to slavery
it was the family the strong family
units
and the faith in god that got people
through that they got people through
jim crow through severe segregation
through all the difficulties
but what really had a negative impact
was when the government came along and
said they're there you poor little thing
i'm going to take care of all your needs
and started implementing policies that
were destructive
to family formation those are the things
that have
hurt the black community the most
um okay that's what he said i
i of course when i hear someone say
something like that i know that it's
going to be quote unquote controversial
but as far as the substance of what he's
saying there's nothing controversial
about that
um what we know this is just a fact that
the black community
in modern america is in dire straits
and that's an understatement there's
never been
anything like what we're witnessing
right now
in terms of the state of the black
community
there's there's never been a community
um that has
so thoroughly abandoned the nuclear
family
70 fatherless rate we all know the
statistics
and that itself is also kind of an
understatement because i think if you go
into the
if you were to specify um in the cities
and the inner cities where the crime
problem is the worst
fatherless rate is higher than 70
percent
we've never seen anything like that
um and it's it's
it's an increasing problem across the
country not just in a black community
also we should note but it is especially
a problem there it's a catastrophic
situation
we've never seen anything like this in
the history of the world
um we've never seen so many kids growing
up without dads
this is another thing uh this is a
something that's proposed by the left
that we abandon the nuclear family
black lives matter for a long time had
that on their website
whatever their phrasing was i don't
remember exactly the phrase because they
because they scrubbed it from their
website after they got a lot of
criticism
which isn't to say that it's not part of
their agenda anymore but they it's it's
not part of their
uh public agenda they're not going to
put it out there for you to read
but it was something like undermine the
the nuclear family or something along
those lines
we have to free ourselves of the nuclear
family well now we're getting a look
at what that what actually happens what
does that look like
in practice when we free ourselves from
the patriarchal
bonds of the of the nuclear family what
we see is just just like we see with
communism
despair death utter unimaginable horror
which is what we're witnessing in the
cities
and that's his point
that uh we could talk about what are the
causes
of the collapse of the nuclear family in
the black community but we we need to
start with acknowledging that it is
it's a real thing it is happening
there's not one
simple cause that we can point to
but it's pretty clear
that the government programs that have
been put in place over the last
several decades meant to help the black
family have not helped
the black family is in a worse state
today than it was before these policies
were
put in place that's the observation that
he's making
pretty obvious pretty straightforward um
and someone who is more than qualified
to make that observation by the way
all right next year this is from uh san
francisco gate.com
the you remember the san francisco gay
men's chorus they put out this song we
have to play the song again for you just
just to remind you what we're talking
about um but the san francisco games
course they put out a song
last week where they're saying that
they're coming for our children they
want to convert our children let's play
the song again and we can all remember
this uh musical masterpiece you think
we're sinful
you fight against our rights you say we
all lead lives you can't respect
but you're just frightened you think
that
we'll corrupt your kids if our agenda
goes unchecked
funny just this once you're correct
we'll convert your children
happens bit by bit quietly and subtly
and you will barely notice it
you can keep them from disco about san
francisco
make him wear pleated pants we don't
care
we'll convert your children
we'll make them tolerant and fair
okay and then it gets then we get the
the entire chorus saying
we're coming for your children they
repeat that over and over again
um and they no as far as i know there
was no gun to their head forcing them to
do this
they made a decision i mean they put
that's just a decision
they put a lot of time and effort into
writing this song
producing it singing it performing it
putting it out there for the world
and the response was very negative
from a lot of people and thank god it
was negative
but now the san francisco gay men's
chorus uh they're saying
they're the victims just so you know the
fact that um
this repulsive piece of propaganda they
put out there
received a negative reaction that makes
them the victims
feel sorry for them not our children who
they say they are quote coming for
but they're the victims so from
sfgate.com says the san francisco gay
men's course says its members are being
harassed online
and receiving death threats after a
satirical video
satirical video that prominently
features the phrase will convert your
children when viral among conservatives
those dastardly conservatives
conservatives pounce
the video which is no longer public on
the group's official accounts but can be
found elsewhere online was first posted
thursday
last week the course says it did not
start picking up steam in right-wing
spaces until the middle of this week
uh and then they put out a statement in
fact i have the statement here
it says this is the statement from the
gay men's court says the san francisco
gay men's course was founded in part to
fight discrimination and bigotry against
all peoples
today our chorus members are facing
death threats vile attacks
false accusations doxing and other forms
of harassment
because of our satirical video
performance message from the gay
community
we let's just stop there what is it
satirizing exactly you're satirizing
yourself
are you satirizing your own agenda
what is the satire
we placed the video in private mode to
quell the intolerance and hateful
responses from mostly anonymous people
upon reflection we've made it live again
for all to see uh
the obviously satirical tongue-in-cheek
humor
we want everyone to judge for themselves
we will not allow ourselves even the
face of death threats
to retreat or bow to attempts to twist
our words
meaning self-deprecation and humor
oh it's self-deprecation now they're
making fun of themselves
did that come through at all and what
you just listened to there you watched
the entire video
self-deprecation
um we are thankful for the efforts of
the san francisco police department and
law enforcement for their quick response
and assistance in handling these threats
the san francisco gay men's course is
dedicated to being role models teaching
and spreading the message of love
inclusion
humor and celebration through our music
oh love and
inclusion
is uh that's that's it's all about love
and and inclusion when you tell parents
we're coming for your children
you know we we need to to teach your
kids like vip
the best possible interpretation
the most generous interpretation for the
san francisco gay men's chorus
is that this was a song meant to mock
conservative parents
and to send the message to us that we
are not capable of raising kind
uh good people and that's why we need
the san francisco gay men's chorus to
step in and uh and the lgbt community
generally speaking
to teach our kids how to be kind and
generous
and tolerant and loving and accepting
that again
is the best possible interpretation
and even on the best possible
interpretation uh
people reacted exactly as anyone should
expect them to react
what do you think people are going to do
of course they're going to be angry
i don't condone death threats but like i
always say with this
anytime someone gets backlash online for
doing or saying something that's truly
objectionable they always claim oh
i got hundreds and hundreds of death
threats maybe you did
i don't actually believe it until you
produce the receipts and you show us
um this idea that there's this deluge of
of death threats
maybe but i don't believe anyone who
claims that until you
until you prove it
and even then that does nothing to get
you off the hook
yeah you shouldn't be getting death
threats but you also shouldn't have
put out the content that you put out
and as far as people reacting in general
just hatefully
yeah that's fully justified
it's a hateful message you put out there
and it gets hateful i hate the message
the message that you want to convert my
children you're coming for my children
um i'm not capable of raising them to be
loving and all of these things
and i need your assistance i hate that
message
and so my response is going to be
hateful towards the message that you
decided to put out there
you're not the victim at all now on a
similar
theme here um
this is from rt.com it says
officials in london's redbridge borough
were left red-faced after a library
event
designed to promote reading supposedly
we'll put the pictures up here okay
there's the picture um
and if you're if you're listening on uh
you know apple podcast or the digital
podcast you got to go over to youtube or
dillywire just so you can see
just so you can see this the picture
here to fully appreciate what we're
dealing with
so this is the um this was an event
designed to promote reading among kids
and it featured a monkey character
in a costume that included a dangling
fake genitalia
and exposed buttocks so this is some guy
in a rainbow they're calling that a
monkey costume i don't know what that is
some kind of furry hairy freak in a
rainbow costume
with a with a a large fake penis hanging
from his costume
and exposed buttocks
he went to the library
to promote reading among kids
why do you need that
it's a good message telling kids that
they should read fully fully support
that message
why do you need him why why is that the
vehicle for that message
well for the same reason that drag
queens are the vehicle because it's not
really about reading at all it's about
desensitizing
and uh and normalizing this behavior to
kids
so this library decided to go this
direction um
and there were a lot of complaints
shockingly people were offended by that
i mean it is a costume
designed every aspect of the costume
is designed to offend people
but now the library and the the the uh
mandinga
arch troupe that put all this together
they've
apologized and said well we're not going
to do that again
and they're acting surprised much like
what the san francisco gay man's course
they're acting surprised i had no idea
people would be upset by this
all we did was send a guy in a hairy
rainbow monkey
with suit with a dildo and exposed
buttocks all we did was send them into
light to a library to talk to kids
what you have a problem with that well i
had no idea
no this was uh they knew what they were
doing
and this is all part of the
desensitization process
but they went a little too far too fast
same with
the song from the gay men's chorus they
knew exactly what they were doing
they're not at all surprised people are
upset
they just didn't think this many people
would be upset that the reaction would
be
as as strident as it is
this is all about desensitizing and
normalizing
and sometimes the people who are
who have put themselves in charge of
that of that agenda
they go a little too far too fast and
they have to back up and say oh okay
okay never mind maybe we'll try this
again in five years
maybe we'll send the guy in the monkey
suit back into the library five years
from now maybe people will be ready for
it then
and you know something they probably
will be sad to say
all right next uh finally here a
uh i want to show you this video ride at
a carnival
because there's an important lesson here
this is a lesson of safety this is at
the cherry festival in traverse city
michigan
one of those rides like every a carnival
ride it just goes around and around in
circles that's all the carnival rides do
and uh let's play the video here so you
can see presumably a lot of kids up on
that ride
and the carnival ride almost falls over
but this is terrifying carl the ride is
about to there there are other angles on
this that show
um that i think showed a little bit
better but this is the angle that i
that i had carnival rides about to fall
over while it's
spinning and then a bunch of men run
over
to grab on to it and kind of
counterweight
and they they probably saved some lives
doing that
so credit to them for that
and the carnival ride operator also when
i first saw this video it it looked like
the carnival ride and i was kind of sl
i showed this video to my wife and i was
i felt bad i was slandering the carnival
ride operator because it looked to me
like he ran away but he didn't it turns
out
he jumped off i guess he hit the kill
switch and then he was the first one
to hang on to the ride um and try to
recruit other people to come over and
help
and yeah like i said he could have saved
lives but
the lesson here aside from
these men uh doing the right thing and
and which is great
instead of standing around there's
someone standing around filming it but
instead of everyone standing around
filming i wonder what's going to happen
next
you actually have looks like 15 or 20
guys leap into action which is which is
good but the other lesson here is
never go on a ride
that was just pulled off of a truck and
reassembled in a parking lot
and three days from now will be broken
down again and put into a truck
and sent to another parking lot it's
a general you go to an amusement park i
mean those are rides that are
permanent they're put in place there are
all kinds of those things are checked
all the time and still we have accidents
every once in a while very rarely
but accidents on carnival rides are much
more common because
these are they're put on a truck and
they're brought to a parking lot and
then they're assembled by who knows
it's not like there's some real
stringent policy in place for checking
these things
and uh it's just it's not the safest
idea
to do that uh and i i know we all grew
up with carnival rides our parents grew
up with it
this might be one of those things i i'm
all about history and tradition
hanging on to the traditions of our
childhood
maybe the traveling carnival thing is
one thing we should leave in the past
possibly let's move now to reading the
youtube comments this is from lauren
says your fans are crying out for sweet
baby gang merchandise don't let this be
a missed opportunity matt
uh i i'm trying not to by the way i
tried to explain
people have been tweeting at my wife
with the the sweet baby gang hashtag
sweet baby gang
and she she was not aware um my wife so
far is not in the sweet baby gang she
didn't even know that it existed
and so i was put in the position and we
were eating dinner and
she's like so what is a sweet baby again
and i had to explain it to her
and as i'm explaining it i just realized
this is the kind of thing you can't
explain
and we should never explain if anyone
ever asks you
what does it mean to be in the sweet
baby gang you just it's like it's like
fight club we don't talk
about it um
angie says never ever play vaxx that
thing up again
well don't tell me what to do angel
angie you should know better than to
tell me what to do
play the song
online day chat find a mate open up the
okay ass
okay yeah profile picture looking tight
chad nice shirt got your bioreading
[Music]
i think i made the point i think i made
the point what do you think's gonna
happen
angie you should know but i have the
maturity of a four-year-old you tell me
not to do it and i'm gonna do it
um jesse says i want sweet baby gang
attire capitalize on this
matthew another comment crying out for
sweet baby gang shirt
i'm tearing up looking at it this is
just this is a
a quick sampling of comments the people
have spoken they want the sweet baby
gang merchandise
um another comment says i want a sweet
baby gang shirt however i feel it should
be more
vague so that everyone is always left
scratching their heads about what it
means
well you're telling me so you're saying
the shirt as it's
where is the shirt okay this shirt is
not gonna make people scratch their
heads wondering
you're telling me that so you want a
shirt that
this will not make people scratch their
heads wondering what the hell that means
that's what you're telling me
that's the greatest thing about this
shirt is people will see that and be
totally confused and disturbed by it
um maximilian says matt you should uh
totally wear the sweet baby gang t-shirt
as your new hideous friday shirt hideous
well you're banned from the show so
you're not going to see what shirt i
wear on friday because you're not
allowed to watch anymore
uh alex says as someone with a master's
degree in history i concur with matt on
the general worthlessness of these
degrees
i have heard this over and over again
from people with master's degrees so i
don't know what else you need to know
if you're if you're thinking about
spending the money on a master's degree
um just talk to people who've gotten
them don't take it for me i don't have
okay i have no college degree at all
what do i know about it
fine talk to people who've gotten the
master's degree and ask them
if they think it was a worthwhile
investment poll like 10 random people
and see what
responses you get
um alex says not only is matt the type
of guy to avoid the elevator for
avoid holding the elevator for a random
stranger but he would also be the guy to
push the closed door button in hopes
that it closes the elevator door faster
i always push the closed door button
every time and certainly
yeah it's it's very convenient because
the closed door buttons right next to
the open door button or the hold door
button and so when someone's running
down the hallway oh
hold that hold that you can always
you're pressing the close button while
saying oh
i'm trying to sorry this dang thing
isn't working
and uh finally jose says i'm throwing
away a third of my life
in a classroom but at least it's to
become a doctor well that's
see that's you're throwing away a third
of your life
in a classroom if you're if you just
keep going back into the classroom
because
you don't know what else to do which is
what a lot of people do they keep
getting more and more degrees and
finding more and more reasons to go back
to school because
they have no real plan for afterwards
um but with graduate school
just like with with uh with undergrad
there is a place for it i've always said
that
i think probably 90 percent of the
people who go to
any kind of school after high school
it's a waste of time they don't really
need to do it
but that leaves 10 percent who really
needs to go and if you want to be a
doctor i fully support i think it's a i
think it's a good idea to have
uh more formal education after high
school for doctors so i'm
fully on board with that just so you
know now we have a new sponsor
on the show uh echelon and i'm excited
about this because look when it comes to
fitness
one excuse that i have made myself many
times an excuse i hear from people all
the time is that i want to get in shape
i just don't have the time to do it
because i live such a busy life and i've
got to make sure to schedule
five hours of netflix binging at the end
of the day
that's why you want to remove that
excuse completely and you can do that
with echelon
echelon's fitness app provides you
thousands of live and on-demand classes
with great music from your favorite
artist with echelon you can work out
anytime day or night
and crush your fitness goals echelons
certified fitness instructors are
supportive engaging and fun they really
know how to get you moving
a full range of affordable workout
equipment is available to you including
stationary bikes smart rowers sleek
fitness screens or the auto folding
treadmill
have all this at your house which means
that you all you need is time to just
walk downstairs to your basement or
whatever
and get in shape and now my listeners
will get a special podcast offer from
echelon for a limited time only
start your 30 day risk free trial offer
with
echelon's ex3 bike for just one dollar a
special risk-free offer
for 30 days with echelon's ex3 bike for
only one dollar to start plus
free shipping the only way to get this
special offer is by going to
echelonfit.com
matt that's e-c-h-e-l-o-n-f-i-t
dot com slash matt echelonfit.com
and you know as a theocratic fascist
myself i i know an authoritarian
takeover when i see one i've been
waiting for one my whole life only i
want to be the one in charge of it so
the authoritarian takeover we're seeing
right now i'm not
i'm not a fan of that um and not to
alarm you but that is what's happening
there is an authoritarian takeover and
i'm not the one in charge that's what
makes it so
difficult from the insertion of critical
race theory into the classrooms an
attempt to brainwash our youth to the
totalitarian lockdown measures
inflicted upon the public by our
government there's no doubt that the
biggest
threat facing america today is an
authoritarian one that's why
ben shapiro wrote the authoritarian
moment to help people like you learn as
much
as they can about how we got here and
most importantly how we can fight back
so don't wait arm yourself with the
knowledge you need to shut america's
tyrants down in their tracks
before it's too late the authoritarian
moment is now available for pre-order at
amazon barnes noble
or any other major bookseller let's get
now to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation i must
once again cancel camila harris
now at this point the bar for camel
cancellations is pretty high if i
canceled her every time she said
something embarrassing or stupid we'd
never be able to talk about anyone else
during this segment
so she has to really bring the good
stuff in order to earn it
and she really did earn it this time
listen
is agreeing to voter id one of those
compromises that you'd support
i don't think that we should
underestimate what that could mean
because in some people's mind that means
well you're going to have to
um xerox or
photocopy your id to send it in to prove
you are who you are
well there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no
kinkos there's no office max near them
people have to understand that when
we're talking about voter id laws
be clear about who you have in mind and
what would be required of them to prove
who they are
of course people have to prove who they
are
but not in a way that makes it them it
almost impossible for them to prove who
they are
almost impossible so there she was on bt
giving her thoughts on voter id
credit where it's due she is she is
correct that uh for people in rural
communities there's no kinkos nearby to
photocopy
an id that's because kinkos doesn't
exist and has not existed for like 15
years or something
rural americans are as near to kinkos as
they are to uh i don't know a heckingers
or an ames department store
and uh because they don't exist they
come to think of it she's correct about
the rest of what she said also i just
moved
from a rural community um where i lived
and the only photocopier we had was an
old amish man named gabriel who would
produce a sketch
using coal and parchment paper in
exchange for a bale of hay and three
years of corn
but old gabe didn't work as fast as he
did in his younger years so it would
take a good six months for you to get
the document sometimes um i didn't even
know that these newfangled photocopiers
existed until i moved to the city in
fact i
i walked into a staples i got here to
nashville and uh is my first time
being you know around buildings and
and cars and everything and i walked
into a staples and uh and i saw people
reproducing images with
these large noisy machines and the first
thing i thought was that it was some
kind of sorcery
especially because it stopped working
the minute i dumped a gallon of holy
water on it
these dang city folk are in league with
the devil i tell you
actually i do unironically believe that
many people in the city are in league
with the devil
but that has nothing to do with their
photocopier technology which contrary to
camille harris's claim
we did have access to out in the country
in fact we had computers and phones not
to mention electricity
and running water we even had them there
fancy things that
kept our food all cold and icy like
refrigerator i think it was called
as a matter of fact um even though i was
a simple country boy
i knew and this is what i did because i
was a little bit far away from the
nearest place to
to to photocopy and uh so so
i knew that i could make photocopies on
my phone
anyone can download an app for free that
will scan
any physical document there's a nice
little tip for you if you didn't know
that
really really convenient i also knew
that i could
buy a copier and printer if i wanted to
i could go on uh what's the uh
the internets and go to amazon you could
order one they'll send it to your house
or if need be i could get in my
horse-drawn carriage and make the
journey to fedex or staples
or the post office or any of a dozen
other places that can handle the
complicated task of photocopying an id
whatever method of photocopy you prefer
the good thing is that wherever you live
if you want to participate in a
presidential election you have four
whole years to figure it out
is there anyone in america who can look
back at the last four years of their
lives
and say that during that entire time
frame they were simply unable to make it
to a staples
even gabriel the amish guy could get it
done in four years
even if the nearest staples was 400
miles away and i was living out in the
wilderness and i had to walk the whole
distance
and yet somehow i had an id in the first
place i could still do it in four
years with time left over time to spare
there is quite literally no conceivable
reason why
any single human being in the modern
united states should be prevented from
voting by voter id laws
and that's probably why people like
camilla harris never provide
any actual examples of any specific real
life people
who wanted to vote and yet were unable
to vote
because during the course of the
preceding four years they were unable to
get an id
and or make a photocopy of one i contend
that such a person does not exist and
note that if such a person did exist
it still would not prove that voter id
laws are bad or unreasonable or
cumbersome
that the law is cumbersome to a small
minority of extremely incompetent people
is not an argument against the law
itself but the anti-voter id position is
so absurd so lacking in any factual
basis whatsoever that i doubt that
any small minority exists
they exist only in the imaginations of
infantilizing politicians like camila
harris
who think that rural americans exist in
some kind of 18th century time warp or
at least
they pretend to think that as fun as it
is to mock this sort of thing
we can't make the mistake of believing
that camilla harris actually believes it
if she did then she would be stupid and
sheltered and ignorant in the extreme
but still
basically well-meaning she's not
well-mean
weaning she knows they all know
that any adult human in the country can
easily qualify to vote even under the
most stringent voter id laws
currently being enacted or proposed
all these laws will do is confirm that
the people voting are who they say they
are
just as you have to prove that you are
who you say you are in order to do
almost anything else in adult life
from buying alcohol to renting a car to
staying at a hotel to procuring an
apartment or a home etc
the people who oppose the laws then
oppose them because they want the
process of voting to be far less secure
than the process of buying a six-pack of
heineken at the gas station
and why is that because they want
voter fraud there is no other reason to
take the position
that they've taken that is pretty clear
and for that reason camilla harris
is canceled and we'll leave it there for
today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire dailywire2021 today
on the ben shapiro show massive
pro-freedom demonstrations break out in
cuba the united states continues its
ill-advised withdrawal from afghanistan
and kamal harris thinks rural people
don't have photocopiers that's today on
the bench bureau shall give it a listen
you